is anybody dating right now I'm not
seeing anybody at all not seeing anyone
at all well how you doing
[Laughter]
[Music]
I just feel like I should be over here
because I look like a baby that sounds
good wait a second so you're saying I'm
old I mean I'm not saying you yeah
I guess I should really do the most
maybe because you know I'm just because
you're doing the most flamboyant you
know what's funny I do agree with that I
feel like you're living your best life
so you feel like you've been through
some things most definitely yeah yeah I
know it sounds like rude but I feel like
you're in the right place as well just
because mostly because you're very
casually dressing you're not trying to
show out anything you're like the
opposite of that but the same but the
same energy I guess I don't even impress
anyone right now which means he's been
maybe hurt a few times I see I didn't
say I didn't certainly say all that but
I said that no I think I hope you
actually ain't here why should I be
middle
[Music]
yeah I think so too could you
automatically put yourself there exactly
I felt good over there but I feel like
you should be last because you're you're
looking your demeanor is like very calm
like you're just like nothing phases me
and yeah I think that puts you at the
least
okay uh just based on certain
experiences because people are shocked
that I have children so they're probably
will be shot um that I was ever married
just because sometimes the way I carry
myself and the funny person I am I
haven't but on the other end I guess
sometimes because of my confidence and
again I will carry myself people might
think I'm being around a whole bunch of
girls and had marriages so he said play
with the coin I feel I feel like you
should still be here just to point out
the fact that you are young and that
Nintendo that bad thing is game enough
that I'm still I'm still living my early
days why you know she's not ready for
commitment yeah she's still playing
games
[Laughter]
not wrong maybe you two should switch
right here yeah right here okay well
yeah I think that's good oh I have one
more thought oh oh okay I'm not saying
anything other than
maybe some more wisdom here maybe we
should put you at that end okay are the
longer years of life okay oh yeah
I like how she she planned that she
works
she said you're always in a great way
Grace comes with age you're good I feel
pretty good about this yeah yeah okay
okay
good humans Jada here there's been a lot
going around the world and in my life
the last few years going through so many
changes can be a lot so this year I've
decided to prioritize my mental health
we want to thank better help for
sponsoring this portion of today's video
better help is the world's largest
therapy service and it's 100 online with
better help you can tap into a network
of over 25 000 licensed and experienced
therapists who can help you with a wide
range of issues all you have to do is
answer a few questions about your needs
and preferences in therapy that way
better help can match you with the right
therapist from their Network then you
can talk to your therapist however you
feel comfortable whether it's via text
chat phone or video call you can message
your therapist at any time and schedule
live sessions when it's convenient for
you and if your therapist isn't the
right fit for any reason you can switch
to a new therapist at no additional
charge with better help you get the same
professionalism and quality you expect
from an office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
more scheduling flexibility and at a
more affordable price check out the link
in the description below or scan this QR
code to get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com Jubilee media that's
better
health.com Jubilee media thanks again to
betterhelp for sponsoring this episode
now let's get back into the video
I think a good question to ask would be
kids ages I have three of them 14 12 and
9.
I think you don't have
it zero kids
I have two daughters 20 year olds and an
eight-year-old um actually I have five
kids there are 24 21 12 5 and 4. I have
a Twan twenty seven are your parents
still together yes I guess they're still
together in heaven no there you go I
love that for us my dad was deceased
when I was nine months and my mom's been
trying to get things together since my
parents are still together
my divorce and later on in life so no
based on some of the stuff that we said
I feel like you still might be the right
bed but we'll continue on and figure
that out yes I think you should be up
there a little bit more like yeah
right here I'll tell you all the way no
no no right here
okay okay all right it's funny because
at first when you said you had like five
kids I was gonna say oh no her but then
that that doesn't necessarily mean
you've been married multiple times five
kids yeah of course and then you not
having any kids means like no red flag
yeah not red flag it's it's it's your
flower whatever color flag you want it
to be but it's like you were like you're
living life here you have this freedom
to you know
depend on the age yeah she's just having
fun right now how old are you doing I'm
30 years old
I'm a thought I think he needs to be
right over here
[Music]
and that's fine yeah and my reason is
um you said your father passed away
early and um your mother was trying to
get it together she is in a relationship
now she remarried once and that was it I
think the way that
um sometimes what we see in our lives
when we're younger really affects our
ability to connect with people when
we're older and so for that reason I
think you and I should switch okay I
feel like I should switch are you like
really breeding us
are we all giving ages because you said
you'll think yeah and how old are you
how old do you think I am okay
how
I'll say the safe answer and say 20. 40
46 no I say my son age oh that's right
and I say when I have my son he says 27
right yeah
so I still think you should stay there
though is anybody dating right now I'm
not seeing anybody at all not seeing
anyone at all so how you doing
is it tender now
where are you at uh I am just
here I'm nowhere just nowhere I'm just
everywhere I guess I mean wherever I
need to be I'm casually dating so what
do you mean casually that means you're
dating and going on multiple dates yes
oh uh I just started a new relationship
congratulations thank you it took me a
while to find but just found someone so
we just started how long did it take you
to find yeah oh wow a few years a couple
years yeah it took that time to heal oh
there was a lot I've been single for
three years and since then it was really
hard to date like I actually thought I
was ready
um a couple months afterwards just to
even go out and have a drink and I was
realizing I was sitting there I'm like
why am I here the fear is starting all
over what is his reflex what is this
what is that so I've been with it seven
years I've been single I was married
when I was before the whole online thing
came on and then when I dabbed into it
it's horrifying as hell because people
are just insane I think online for the
most part but at the same token there's
also I was like more focused on I want
to be there for my kids 100 and my
career and that was where my focus was
it's always a thing where I see someone
like oh she's fine and then I'm like but
then I gotta talk to her and then I
gotta figure out I gotta commit to all
this work and it's going to be and then
after a while back now forget it it's
too much of a hustle and I'll just move
on also being the single father thing is
very interesting then the women know
that you're probably going to be like
the fifth option you know it's my kids
they're me my career than you and that
doesn't they they think it's a good idea
it sounds great it sounds good until
they fall for you and they're like oh
you want more I'm like I can't give you
more and then I bet it's probably
actually hard to actually date someone
that doesn't have kids because they feel
like they're gonna need to be number one
and don't understand the fact that you
know when you have children that's my
priority yes like if they call me right
now all that I need to go I believe yes
I'm gone and the most important thing is
how they talk about their ex that's
that's very important if I if I see you
this dog in your ex all the time I'm no
it ain't gonna work it's like dating
after divorce uh for me it was hard to
snap out of I'm not in a relationship
anymore that was hard you get like a
little bit of depression I mean
obviously you're grieving over your loss
of your relationship you do therapy you
you try to make yourself out of your
funk or whatever after doing that then
you're feeling like you're ready for
dating but everything was online
um it's hard to meet in person you know
it's kind of like a cheat sheet when you
do it online you know because you you
know what you're sort of getting even if
you're getting catfished you still have
a cheat sheet you still have an idea of
what this person may or may not be for
me what's easy no fault okay you're over
here
you're over here working in an
entertainment business you know you meet
every time new people if you are
friendly you know it's easy to start to
have one website action and everything
and date occasionally you know I think
you should move me yeah I'm not that way
no I'm getting a different vibe like you
were in a very long-term relationship
for a long time and then absolutely
crushed you when it ended and that to me
feels like a not like over here yeah
okay yeah yeah
y'all might be similar yeah
here's a question when you were single
what did you learn about yourself I
learned that I need to stop being a
people pleaser and I needed to start
going for what I wanted and
compromise from there I guess oh you
gave me goosebumps yeah sorry
oh thank you yeah you can help me that's
fine
I learned that uh many of the issues I
had in my marriage had a lot more to do
with me than I was willing to admit
um before my divorce so now that I'm
single and I've had time to reflect I'm
like oh a lot of ownership yeah I was
you know more romantic and more just
really flat-want so when I got married I
went I realized that I was actually
putting stuff in the back burner like I
was losing myself because I was pleasing
someone and hoping that I have that
stability for the you know for my kids
but during the three years now I'm
actually found myself so that's good I
found myself oh hold on I'm couch
so I was like you know what I'm gonna go
to therapy because it's myself that
needs healing and I don't want my kids
to grow up feeling what they're feeling
for the you know the divorce so I
actually started learning like oh I used
to love poetry I'm like why did I stop
oh I remember I wrote a poem a long time
ago in the beginning of our relationship
and he just put it away since he's been
gone I've been accomplishing a lot of my
goals and in a way I'm kind of scared to
actually get in another relationship but
at the time I think I'm actually ready
for like a full relationship now because
of the the self-healing that already
been through the time is short you know
you don't know how long time you'll have
it's no sense to stay with somebody if
you're not happy it's better to don't
take any from anybody if you can
improve my life would be okay if you not
improve and put me down I don't need you
no
sister I I've kind of grow up with no
I'm not so happy family you know having
problems all the time what I was small
you know I said I would not stay married
if I'm not happy if I wanted to marry 10
times I have married 10 times I hope not
that that supports the proves I think
while you're right there in a very good
way you know what I mean thank you yeah
how long did it take you and just think
of whatever you want to get your divorce
it took me probably eight months
um the reason being the first thing I
said is that we're not going to court
because I'm not taking anything from you
and you're not taking anything from me
and we're not doing this whole Hollywood
divorce thing let's focus on the kids
and that was it it's hard for me to
explain my situation without giving up
too much information because I I am
finalizing divorced but we're still
fighting over kids you're in the right
place yeah oh thanks
well we started it during quarantine and
we didn't get to do anything because
quarantine really prolonged everything
yeah so I would say my separation plus
divorce took took a couple years once I
filed the paperwork it only took like 21
days but I think from the time I said I
would like to be separated to the time I
filed the paperwork was about six months
I would say about six months I did all
the paperwork myself so I did a paper
for myself was one year next year for
work and it could be signed on both
spots I think you should move right here
and the reason for that is because you
initiated your divorce like someone
who's been divorced before and I feel
that in my soul so
I'm not thinking you should actually be
over there because you basically only
been speaking more on just one so I
think you should you and him should move
right here yeah did you face any stigma
like as a divorcee just on social media
I think I see a lot of people who have a
lot of opinions on the fact that I've
been divorced and not only that I've
been divorced but that I'm happy and
celebrating my life now it's very people
really just don't like that culture
taught us
that this is what you do you grow up you
find a person that's your person you
marry them and you stay with them
forever and so we were taught that and
when you don't do what Society has kind
of programmed us all to do I think
people don't know what to do with that
and so yeah I do think there's a stigma
you know I was supposed to be this like
super you know Christian girl and I was
terrified of what other people would
think of me or how I would be portrayed
if I did get divorced like would that
make me less qualified to my peers in
the church so yeah I think it definitely
played a role in like the length of time
it took me to know when I should or
shouldn't be in something and when it
was time to leave a lot of people judge
it's a lot of judgment even though they
say they don't judge it they judge you
but you just I feel like you just keep
on moving the way you you want to move
they're not living your life it's only
the first stigma I felt was actually
from the X because in term one it was
like oh I'm the dad so you're just gonna
see him on the weekends or you're gonna
fly back to England and never see it
because I never understood Concept in
general is like there's two people that
are raising kids it takes two people for
the most part and if they're willing to
be to raise their kids them you know
they both should do it yeah there's
definitely that stigma of you know
especially when it comes to black
fathers and how they're not involved in
their lives kind of thing yeah how has
divorce affected your opinion on finding
Future Love marriage in general have you
ever heard from you in a bit yeah yeah
it doesn't affect me I I believe in love
if I will find that good if not I'm
still trying nothing what can put me
down I'm ready but I need to make sure
that I uh screen them first because I
was talking to someone in in three
months I actually tested him I was like
hey come help me with my garage and I'll
pay you and so he took the money I think
he cleaned my garage and I was like oh
oh can I uh get a massage I bet you you
need a massage I'm gonna need that
hundred dollars back if you test them
they're gonna show the action and that's
what it is it's all about action at the
end I feel like Jocelyn you should go to
the top oh my god really I got the most
the reason is because you're testing
people and I feel like that's a top
oh just because I got five kids I
understand I'm telling you she's over
here
Jocelyn actually yeah you know what I
agree I think uh Justin should be in
between no way you think it's less yes
because of the testing yes because
everyone she's testing she's never gonna
get to the marriage part because they're
failing all the tests based on the test
stuff and the test the test that she's
giving are kind of like not the best
test for save so that's why all the man
had to do was not take the money and
then she would have married him no I
would not
okay
all right whose fault was it
I think we just lost communication and
lost touch with each other we have no
problems with each other now I think the
divorce was actually a good thing for us
because now we can still be friends
whose fault was it for you I got to say
it was
I'm not going to answer that question do
the fifth I'll take it
no more reading me sir
whose fault was it it was hers
she cheated so that's that's the end of
it for me I'm the one that actually cost
the cheating or did she try to talk I
mean what is that I have because that's
interesting he said that what does that
mean about the fight do I need to take
these tails off but it makes me feel
comfortable
I don't think there's any excuse for
cheating like if you don't want to be in
the marriage Just Bounce we gotta move
you back over here I want to put you
here yeah
my thought was just a lot of the thought
process being focused on the other
person rather than on the self um the
past conversation even when you spoke
about you know if you thought
relationship I should finish I was like
oh maybe she's being a little bit more
around the block than I thought so
put you right here so is this our final
answer
I don't agree but what do you want no
speak your mind I feel like you need to
be I agree
no no no uh oh yeah oh Closer Closer
because yeah everything yeah say it was
we're so emotionally charged about it
she's not so emotionally charged she's
been doing it like seven times
[Laughter]
I don't know that you should be on the
end I agree I don't think I should be at
the end like this this is completely off
all right you should come down here we
should move up because I think you
should be right now I'm number one again
I think this is a final answer all right
that's it we're done
starting with the fifth spot we have
Marcos
in the fourth spot Leon
spot
[Laughter]
joshlyn
in the second spot Marissa
okay and in the first spot Nicoletta
oh my innovator we're not supposed to be
um I've had one divorce and I would say
it's just fell out of love and
communication communication I have had
one divorce and nice and simple she
cheated I have one divorce and I'm
currently going through one all right uh
I hello I've been married and divorced
twice before 30 so I have two divorces
and
um both my fault I decided to leave and
I initiated both because I have
attachment issues that's for another day
okay
I was full-time divorce
I don't know why I'm clapping experience
and every time was different to a reason
you know first time was gambling second
time was cheating
current time was cheating with another
size of Sex
and the whole time was have the business
together and
start to fight from here and never have
business again with a partner
are you getting married the fifth time
his Fifth Harmony I hope it will be the
good one a win is a win we did pretty
good I think the only thing we had
switched up
keep me right here I mean give it a few
more months you'll be right there
you're literally I think it's really
nice to be in a room with people who
have also gone through it
um being someone who has that motto I've
been married and divorced twice before
30. I do see so much hate and I think
people forget that you're human and I
love meeting you because your
personality and your Vibe and you you
knowing that you're enough and that the
right person will come is amazing even
with four divorces and I think it gives
me hope because I feel so much shame in
myself for having two divorces and and
seeing you thrive and be happy is just a
really encouraging thing for me to see
I'm kind of used to divorce I've seen
divorce a lot in my fan any friends and
all that stuff and it's just a thing
that you need to help people out with
when they're going through it people
feel like divorce is kind of like a
disease I don't like the fact that
people tend to leave you alone and
ignore you whether it's your fault or
not your fault when you separate you're
grieving the loss of a life your life
together and I think when someone's
grieving you need to be there for them
interesting you said that because I
found myself actually helping people who
are going through divorce like even
though I'm a little cynical when it
comes to marriage and everything else I
still try and put a positive light on
you know things can yeah things can go
better you know this this life after
divorce so on and so forth yeah
I'm single my name is Josh Land and I am
40 years old I have five kids but you
don't got to worry about them I'm free
Thursday through Monday so holla
usernames throw out your usernames oh
I'm good okay